tell you number one that most of you say
you want to be successful but you don't
want it bad you just kind of want it you
don't want it better than you want to
party you don't want it as much as you
want to be cool you most of you don't
want success as much as you want to
sleep
some of you love sleep more than you
love success and I'm here to tell you
today if you're going to be successful
you've got to be willing to give up
sleep you got to be willing to work off
for three hours of sleep two hours if
you really want to be successful some
days you will have to stay up three days
in a row because if you go to sleep you
might miss the opportunity to be
successful